My name is Jack Sim from the World Toilet
Organization. I think that's there's no joint
politic conflict possible because people will
then find the opportunity to invest back home
internally. And they can invest back home
in their poorer region to help close the income
gap. Or they could also invest in the night
economy. For example in Singapore there is
no poorer region. There is a waste of economy
time at night where offices are empty, roads
are empty, and all these national assets cost
trillions of dollars and if we invest in the
night economy then we can get people to work
at night. People don't usually want to work
at night when the family lives in the day.
But if they moved a higher family into the
night and there's night school, there's night
shopping, there's night recreation, night
responsibility around the country 24 hours,
you can internally generate enough economic
activities until the new recovery comes. By
then you might still want to work 3 shift.